today erwin and i are going to be
giving a talk on scaling transformers
through sparsity
and the kind of sparsity we're going to
be talking about today is the kind where
you know each input can get you know
either a different set of weights or
have a different amount of computation
applied to it
or do you want to start it off
yeah
so
i guess the overall motivation for this
line of work is that um
you know the community has kind of
realized that scale uh is perhaps one of
the most important access to
to focus on for obtaining strong
performance and there's almost like this
sort of
ongoing arms race right now with
different labs and different
institutions um
sort of competing for training the
largest
uh uh you know models
and so uh maybe this dates back from
early uh 2020 with a paper from open ai
called
scaling laws for neural language models
where they find that model performance
follows the predictable
overall
scale sort of as a parallel with uh
model size
in terms of either
compute or also just uh
you know
uh parameters
and so this uh this scaling law kind of
generalizes over multiple orders of
magnitude
and you know that gives us the
confidence that if we are to train very
large models
uh you know we can expect you know
certain performance uh just by
extrapolating extrapolating these uh
scaling laws
so in that paper they also
find
the interesting
observation that
basically larger models are more sample
efficient
and so you know if you have a fixed
compute budget
uh
you can sort of
you know you you can predict what what
is the size what is the optimal model
size or fixed compute budget
and um
the the overall observation is that
uh you know you you'd rather train very
large models
from for less tests and train smaller
models for more training steps
and so these models are scaled um
you know through
[Music]
basically those so the paper focuses on
dance models right where you just
increase the model dimensions
um but they're not looking at sparsely
and so
is
is a new dimension that you can use to
scale architectures
um you know and this is sort of the
the focus of the talk
and so the sparsity we are where we're
mentioning here is basically you will
have
sparsely activated weights
based on the network inputs so every
input will go to
a roughly similar amount of computation
but will be applied different weights
and so this dates back to 1991 with a
paper called adaptive mixtures of local
experts
and was recently revisited
by noam chazier and colleagues at google
brain
with lstms
where they replaced so sort of the feed
forward
networks in lstms with mixture of
experts
and so the way this works there roughly
is that
you will have multiple experts each
implementing
you know a small network or in that case
i think just a
dense matrix multiplication
um and so you have an additional getting
network um
shown in green here
that
uh outputs a probability distribution of
our
experts that each token should be sent
to
so this probably distribution is
computed as a softmax
and once you have it
you select a few experts
so
there are different strategies maybe
we'll talk about it later on and the
output is simply sort of the weighted
mixture of all selected xbox outputs
so that they've been pretty uh
successful in
[Music]
primarily in
translation
but there was some you know
you know some
complexities that another
brother used in nlp
and so the switch transformer paper um
addresses uh some of those and we will
be discussing
how to
you know how to
fix training disabilities or reduce
communication costs and
and uh reduce my complexity
all right barry you want to go
sure yeah so yeah so one kind of
approach that we're gonna have uh for
sparsity is the uh switch transformer
which is kind of like a
simplified mixture of expert variant
along with some other improved you know
training and fine-tuning techniques that
allow it to you know
be stably trained and also you know
perform better when fine-tuned done a
lot of downstream tasks
and so yeah so the switch transformer
kind of uh model works as the following
so you have some transformer model that
has you know self-attention
and feed forward layers and the idea is
that we replace maybe one every two or
one every four feet forward layers with
a switch transformer layer
so you can see on the left is like one
kind of layer block which is self
attention then add normalize then a few
forward layer then add normalize and in
this case we're replacing the normal
feed forward layer with the like switch
layer
and we can see an illustration of this
on the right so
on the right we can see that the the
layer has two inputs um one is the token
more the other is the token parameters
and we can see that these you know
embedding representations will get sent
to a router which is exactly how it
works in the mixture of expert so the
router is basically just going to be you
know getting a distribution over all of
the experts so in this case we can see
that the the highest probability is
going to
the like the expert number two out of
the four experts and then the the right
token is actually having the most
probability on the first uh feed forward
weight which is like the first expert
so yeah we can see here that like what
we're going to do is in the switch
transformer which is very simple is just
send it to the highest probability
expert and so here we can see where the
adaptive computation lies where we'll
have four sets of weights
there's some shared uh weights and
computation across all the tokens for
example the self-attention layer is
computed exactly the same for the more
token and for the parameters token
but in the sparse switch layer we can
see that like actually the inputs are
while having the same amount of floating
point operations applied to them
actually have different weight matrices
uh next slide
yeah so that's the kind of high level i
deal with switch transformer is that you
know instead of sending a token to
multiple different experts which can
also increase the communication costs as
i'll go into a little bit later it also
just like significantly kind of
simplifies the algorithm by just only
sending it to one expert
so
for the improved training methodology we
focused on three different things to
help improve the training of sparse
models the first was selective precision
which like allows these sparse models to
be trained in lower precision formats
which is incredibly important most of
the models we train we really don't want
to be using float32 because it's just
slower to compute it also when you're
communicating tensors across different
processes and stuff it's twice the is
twice as slow just because there's twice
as many things
also we have some initialization tricks
and some training tricks as well for
allowing them to be trained more stably
especially as the models grow in size
which is like a new initialization
method along with like a a change to the
learning rate schedule
and third since that our models have so
many more parameters we do notice like
definitely different overfitting
dynamics especially once we fine-tune
these models that have been you know
pre-trained on all of the internet on
these small tasks with maybe only 50 to
100 000 examples that they can be much
more prone to overfitting so we also
look at some
custom uh you know regularization to
help prevent some of the overfitting
that we observe and finally we also talk
about this differentiable load balancing
technique we make
which kind of allows you know each
expert to roughly get the same amount of
tokens
because you know this is very important
especially given that we're you know
want the stuff to be efficient on
hardware we want roughly each expert to
have similar amounts of tokens sent to
it and so to kind of encourage this we
tack on an additional like load
balancing loss along with our
cross-entropy loss that we're training
with
uh next slide okay so here i'm gonna go
into selected precision so yeah again so
like when we're training large models
it's really important that we should be
able to train them in lower precision
formats so instead of each you know
weight being an activation being 32 bits
we want to shrink it down to 16 bits and
we use like the b float 16
representation and what we found out of
the gate is that you know these models
are just unstable
especially the sparse models are much
more unstable than the dense models in
terms of like you'll train it for 10 20
000 steps and then the losses would just
diverge this was something that we you
know frequently encountered
and so one key thing that we found is
that basically
you need to be casting a part of the
computation in um float32 for these
models to be able to be trained um
stably
and the the key component that we found
that you need to cast is the like router
computation and essentially you know
we can go into the technical details a
little bit more later but basically
anytime that there's like these
exponentiation functions it's very
important that we are you know having
higher and higher precision because of
round off errors that can then
drastically change the output of some
kind of you know exponentiation function
so for example like if you have an
exponentiation function and you change
it by 0.1 or 0.2 or 0.3 this can
drastically change the output of like
exponentiating it especially depending
on how large the input is
so yeah so this was like a very
important thing and it basically doesn't
change the compute at all and allows the
models to just be significantly more
stable
next slide
so the the second thing we looked at is
also the initialization scale so like
the standard way that we were
initializing these models
we found to also just make the models
much more prone to being unstable and or
just performing worse so one thing that
we did that we found was very effective
was to just simply make the
initialization scale much smaller and
when we did this we found that you know
the quality just like drastically
improved it was like a very simple fix
uh next slide
and the third thing i mentioned where
since we noticed that these models are
much more prone to overfitting since
they just have significantly more
parameters
is that we also use much more dropout
for the expert layers only so here we
can see we took we have like you know
the t5 base which is a dense model and
then we have a bunch of different switch
variants on that and we found to be the
most effective on these four different
fine tuning tasks was just to really
significantly increase the dropout rate
inside the expert layers and we found
that this was pretty effective for
combating the overfitting
next slide
yeah we have a question oh awesome
yeah okay let me take a look
do you want to go ahead yeah i can ask
um it was just in reference to that
previous table where you have throughput
and precision
um it just seemed surprising to me that
you could match this 1390 number
we're using selective precision it seems
like i would expect it to be like
something in between
yeah so it essentially comes down to the
fact that like there's maybe a little
bit of noise
sampling with the speed and the only
part we're casting is the router which
is you know maybe like so it's such an
insignificant portion of the computation
and there's zero communication there
that it's essentially like a free
operation in the network so whether you
cast the b flow 16 or flow 32 it doesn't
actually impact the speed at all
within the precision so we can actually
measure the speed
and also these architectures only use
fast layer uh ones one every four layers
and so
yeah essentially the float32 part is
kind of very negligible in the entire
yeah
it's like for example i think like off
the top of my head it's like 140th the
computation that would cost for you to
do the first like like weight matrix
multiply in like a dense relu dense
layer or something so it's a very very
small part and yeah we're not using them
very frequently like everyone mentioned
as well
yeah and then you know just like a quick
point in this like i won't go into some
of the technical details but yeah we
definitely you know since we're training
these things on hardware and we really
like i think a big part of the mixture
of experts paradigm is that these things
are designed such that it maps really
efficiently to hardware
so we want to be doing dense matrix
multiplies and for this to work really
well we we also want to be able to have
you know roughly equal amount of tokens
going to each of the different experts
and
what like i think the this isn't that
sensitive to the load balancing
formulation like we tried a few things a
lot of them worked but yeah essentially
you definitely want some kind of load
balancing loss added on when using
sparsity
yeah next slide
yeah erin go ahead
yeah so
so the frameworks with the library we
use uh rely on static shapes uh for
okay yeah so we so
xla
so the compiler um for uh tensorflow and
mesh tensorflow
expects static shapes for tensors
however
the computations in switch transformers
are dynamic because
you know because of the router right
like
different inputs will be routed to
different
experts
and so we need to
specify ahead of time how many tokens
will be sent to each export
and so we will introduce this expat
capacity um hyper parameter
to specify that and that's going to be a
static number
which says how many tokens each expert
can process
and so in practice we instead
parametrize this by having
a quantity called the capacity factor
so we have an example here um
so you know so
the bottom row
is
okay so is a bunch of tokens on one
device and then you need to sort of
route those tokens to multiple devices
or multiple exports
so if too many tokens are routed to a
single export
some tokens will be dropped because as
we said like
export had a fixed capacity
so that's the example on the left where
the capacity factor is one and that
basically means that the total um
there's no like extra buffer
for uh rolling tokens
um so instead of that we can use a
capacitive factor that's larger than one
so on the right you have an example with
1.5
um
so that means that now each export has
like sort of three slots that can
process three tokens
and so that prevents token dropping
because we have more capacity but the
issue is that this means higher
you know this more expensive
communication across
devices
yeah okay so that was it
yeah go ahead oh yeah so yeah so one
thing that we also experimented with was
this um
method called no token left behind and
the idea was the following so
since we have to have like you know a
fixed batch size for each expert and
there can be token dropping we kind of
we're thinking that hey yeah having
tokens dropped or like you know having
some tokens not having any computation
applied to it
is probably hurting the model
performance so what if we do a
multi-stage routing procedure so first
you do the normal routing where it's
like you send each token to its highest
probability expert but then any drops
tokens you then send to their second
highest probability expert and so forth
and so on where you can basically repeat
this process to guarantee that no tokens
are being dropped
interestingly actually this approach
didn't empirically improve model
performance of anything it actually kind
of hurt it
and we thought that was actually very
interesting
and i think the intuition is that you
know once the model learns it wants to
send a token to one expert
like it really wants to have that
computation applied to it and just
applying some other computation
doesn't you know have at all the same
property along with it actually maybe
being potentially detrimental
so yeah we thought that was pretty
interesting as we were very optimistic
this would potentially you know get
improved performance but it ended up not
really making a difference and we found
this quite surprising
we have a question from
um
i think it will actually kind of like
address literally the last point that
you brought up um i think when i think
about like a mixture of experts um
usually like they specialize in like
different things right so i think it's
like um
just like
a lot like i was just wondering um
like if you send it to like the second
best or whatever
um
like what if like all of your tokens
would be particularly good for like one
expert and then you only like
process let's say like 20 of your tokens
so that ends up being better than
rerouting them to anything else
exactly
yeah so yeah even if you're dropping a
lot of tokens it's not beneficial to be
sending them to the second third or
fourth best thing
and one actually interesting property
that we you know noticed about these
models is they're surprisingly robust to
token dropping especially during fine
tuning so yeah so in the standard
paradigm what we'll do is we'll
pre-train this thing we'll have some
load balancing loss which makes the the
tokens pretty balanced actually
but then during fine-tuning where it's
like we really want to fine-tune it on a
specific task we actually studied this
exact question and we were studying does
it help to have a load balancing loss
during fine tuning or not and so if you
have the load balancing loss yeah that
kind of is encouraging you know for the
specific task we want to try to have you
know all the experts be used versus
turning it off whereas there's
definitely some you know prior
specialization and it's actually much
better to just turn the auxiliary loss
off and even if it's like you know 60 to
70 of the tokens are being dropped that
actually performs much better than you
know having all the tokens balanced but
doesn't a load balancing loss encourage
basically all the experts to learn very
similar weights and then just
randomly assign your tokens
because then it does matter to which
expert stuff is being sent to
so when we use the load balancing loss
like the routing mechanism is definitely
learned so the model definitely is
encouraged to you know choose an expert
that it wants to send it to for good
right but like if all the experts learn
the same weights
then
the the router learns basically oh it
doesn't matter where you send it to
so if you encourage load balancing you
encourage
technically that like you want any loss
to fit with any expert right
i mean that's maybe the extreme behavior
if you have a very high sort of load
balancing loss coefficient
but in practice that coefficient is kind
of tuned and we observe that for you
know small enough values
um the router still learns like cement
like meaningful routing
yeah because it's like a balance between
this like you know cross entropy loss
and this load balancing loss and so on
one hand yeah you definitely want to
encourage the model to be balanced then
on the other hand you also want to just
get good empirical performance and yeah
the model is able to definitely like on
one hand
learn and specialize the experts where
they have different weights such that
it's like you know definitely it expects
certain tokens to be sent to certain
aspects but on the other hand still be
reasonably balanced so that the models
are officially run on like modern
hardware
exactly
we also have a question from the
classroom
so question the question that i want to
ask is
it seems to me like this is a very
experimental talk we're talking about
floating point precision we're talking
about different approaches and currently
work well and whenever we're dealing
with your clients there's a question of
what is the research question and i feel
like i miss that so what are we trying
to answer with all these experiments
yeah i think the i think the high level
research question is like you know can
we
you know create models
that are you know
like doing adaptive computation from the
standpoint of like you know can we try
to make models more simulate the
dynamics that we think models should you
know most naturally use which is
different inputs that have different
amounts of computation applied have
different weights applied to them you
know and basically all of this basically
we're trying to research and like figure
out how can we create like a new
framework for these models to be trained
as opposed to their dense counterparts
that you know for every input are always
having the same exact computation
applied so that's interesting because
when you say the same exact computation
applied one might imagine that um
like to me the immediate thing is about
how long to deliberate about something
what i mean by that is if we want to
have variable length computation you
could imagine that i could have a short
amount of computation or it could have
much longer computation but this idea of
like why then do we instead consider the
dimension of different computation i
mean assuming of course that these
experts do indeed learn different things
which i think you'll get to in
yeah
so yeah why do we immediately jump to
thinking about specialized experts as
opposed to thinking about variable
length computation
so yeah so this is actually we actually
go into some variable length computation
stuff later in the talk and i feel like
they're both actually just important
axes that should both be pushed on i
think
i guess yeah i guess it's kind of you
know
i guess
yeah i'm not freezing my question but
what i'm trying to understand is you're
thinking about why did you decide to
attack this one first i want to
understand why your team chose to go
this direction first
yeah absolutely so i think that one
empirically it seems that sparsity has
led to better empirical results in the
field of deep learning than adaptive
computations so far and i think the way
that we use these things maps really
well to our modern hardware
which is also very promising and i think
the way we were kind of looking at it is
like sparsity is like a first step
towards doing more interesting and
general adaptive computation
where and we're and you know because i
think it's like you know this stuff is
complicated and typically starting from
something that works well is better than
necessarily like you know
you know trying something that's not
necessarily as proven out and then
trying to like get it to work really
well so i think we're kind of starting
from sparsity which like you know gnome
chazier and others got to work really
well in the context of lstms we were
kind of interested in you know let's
pour some of this to transformers let's
get it working really well and then
let's slowly start expanding towards a
lot of the other natural questions that
you mentioned whereas like okay whereas
instead of you know different weights
per core let's also maybe have a
different computation per core and all
of this so that's i guess how we were
kind of building the natural like you
know build up and progression of our
research got it cool thank you
what do you think or anything else to
add
um
yeah i mean i guess i kind of see
adaptive computation and sparsity as
you know related but separate things so
you know especially is more like
different parameters for each example
and adaptive computation might be more
different
amount of flops
and we have some of that with the token
dropping but that's kind of uh
no that's not the the main um
domain motivation
uh definitely as barrett mentioned
uh i would say you know no one really
has figured out adaptive computation yet
for deep learning and what one reason is
because we have this uh
you know accelerators right expect
expect like
sort of you know
we need to work with like batch like
data parallelism right so
um and all of our accelerators and our
frameworks use this spmd paradigm where
you're kind of supposed to apply the
same computation to
to examples um
and so if you look at the literature you
have you know walks like universal
transformers
where they replace the feed forward in
the transformer by
um just a recurrent weight and so it's
kind of like an lstm on each token
and the lcm can stop at different times
based on some
criteria but the way these things are
implemented is just through masking
um because
it needs to be implemented in the spmd
programming style
um and so definitely sparsity was kind
of like easier to get to work
first and also there were some prior
results with lstm so
in terms of like the first question you
know sort of what's our research
question here it's just like oh can we
design more efficient models
and sparsity is this new axis that
hasn't been explored that much and yeah
i think that
you know i i'm happy with just that
being the research question
great okay
um yeah so next slide
yep
oops
yeah again so kind of putting it all
together so the switch transformer layer
selects an expert like just the top
expert and then incorporates a bunch of
the general sparse model improvements to
you know allow it to fine-tune better
allow it to you know
be more regularized allow it to you know
be trained with lower precision formats
and a lot of like technical details to
just get them training and working well
um yeah so one thing that we also wanted
to do was uh a comparison between like
top one and top two routing since top
two routing was kind of the you know
most popular technique
and so here we can see we have two
different dense models trained of
different sizes and we're going to be
looking at like the the pre-training
like negative log perplexity so um
yeah the bigger the number the better
so next slide
so here so and what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be studying them
at different capacity factors so a
capacity factor of 2.0 basically means
that there is enough buffer for two
tokens to be sent to every single expert
and we're going to be comparing like top
one versus top two routing
and also comparing their speeds along
with their like time to get some like
threshold quality
uh okay yeah so here we can see in the
capacity factor 2.0 case
that um
the moe models outperform switch
transformer which makes a lot of sense
like since switch transformer is only
you know sending uh like a top one token
to each expert the mixture of expert is
sending um you know two tokens so that
makes sense that this extra buffer will
be like disproportionately beneficial
for the mixture of expert models
and so we noticed that and next slide
all right yeah next
now when we so the really interesting
parts for the top one routing becomes
when we lower the capacity factors so
having a high capacity factor is bad for
many reasons one of which is it really
incurs more of these you know
communication costs for sending tokens
to the correct experts it also incurs
more compute costs and also incurs like
a lot of memory overhead so if you can
get this lower it's it's usually like a
very very good thing
and so what we see here is that switch
transformer actually outperforms mixture
of experts when you have like a lower uh
capacity factor and we can see that the
time to quality threshold we um you know
yeah we get there much quicker and so
even across the 2.0 and the 1.25
capacity factors like the kind of pareto
optimal thing we saw in our setup is to
use switch transformer at a lower
capacity factor just due to the fact
that while the quality is worse a little
bit worse on a step basis it's just like
much faster to run so it's kind of the
pareto optimal decision
uh next slide
and we could also be seeing that like
for capacity factor 1.0 again we can see
that this really disproportionately
benefits switch transformer and is even
better for on a pareto standpoint than
the 1.25 capacity factors
and interestingly since you know moe
also does like a little bit more
computation we can also just increase
the uh amount of compute done elsewhere
in the model and we can see that that's
like a much more efficient allocation of
compute
so yeah overall our takeaway is that
yeah lower capacity factors using up on
routing is more pareto efficient than
you know using like top two routing at
higher capacity factors
next slide
um oh and you can take it over
okay so
next we'll look at how
sweet transformer scales
as a function of the number of exports
in the switch layers
and so on the right side here you see a
plot that shows perplexity
versus training steps for different
switch architectures ranging from t5
base which is basically no expert or a
single expert
up to 128 experts
and so you see that as we increase the
number of experts which also increases
number of parameters of sports space
parameters
you get sort of uh speed ups
you know you get increasing speed ups
about the dense baseline and are like
sort of diminishing returns
to uh
you know multiplying to you know
increasing the number of experts as well
so the previous
figure was looking at
perplexity versus training steps here we
look at perplexity versus strength time
so that includes you know
all the you know additional
communication costs when you have more
experts or
um
you know comparing comparing to the
dense baseline
and so this is for switch bass or then
super t5 bass and um we observe 7x up to
7x speedups over t5 bass
and so you know just to
maybe contextualize these these numbers
like
you know 7x speedups and deep learning
are pretty hard to obtain and so
i think this is one of the
you know one of the results that um
[Music]
you know can spark a lot of interest in
sparse models
even if it's only for pre-training for
now like just having that number is like
you know maybe there's a
there's a significant
um
there's something significant that can
be obtained here
okay so spot scaling laws
so here we'll look at uh
sort of loss versus
sparse model parameters which are
increased by increasing the number of
experts
and so similarly to the sort of you know
neural scaling wallpaper
we observed that
as you increase
the parameters
which the sparse parameters and keep the
flaps fixed
uh you get diminishing like consistent
gains by diminishing gains
okay so now we're going to compare
export parallelism and molar parallelism
so we we introduced sparsity or export
parallelism as a new dimension to
uh scale models but of course
there's the other one for dance model
which is simply model parallelism where
you know model weights are partitioned
across cores once they are
above the maximum size that you can feed
on a single core
all right so
yeah parrot has to left this export
parallelism here
yeah so so essentially what we're doing
is is um
yeah we're kind of comparing a switch
base model versus the the dense base and
we're also comparing against a larger
dense model that has used um model
parallelism and we can see that you know
because basically when we want to scale
up model size we kind of have two axes
that we can either go through we can
either increase the number of flops by
scaling through model parallelism or
increase the number of parameters by
scaling through sparsity and so we can
see that you know even compared to like
you know a dense model that's been
scaled up through model parallelism that
sparsity is still at the scale a more
effective way to scale up the model
by you know still getting 2.5 x speed
ups over this larger um dense model that
was using uh model parallelism
cool so uh
yeah
basically here t5 large is the dance
mode that uses other parallelism
yeah go ahead
okay
yeah and so one thing that we also
wanted to look at is like you know are
these expert models effective if you
have like you know really small amount
of computer just a small amount of
experts so typically when we're
designing these models like we have one
expert per core but if you don't have
like a large cluster to run these things
on let's say you just have like a gpu
with two cores or something like is
having two experts more effective than
just like a dense model and the the
answer is yes so we can see even pretty
good scaling properties even with like a
tiny amount of experts
which is very very promising for these
models to be used even in like much
lower compute regimes
next slide
okay so yeah so
yeah so we'll look at um
you know
what things look like when we use
different uh types of parallelism namely
expert parallelism to add exports
smaller parallelism to sharp model ways
across course and also data parallelism
which is sort of the
dominant paradigm in deep learning at
the moment
and so
you know i guess you know in the
previous slides we mostly talked about
export parallelism but of course you
know dance models and large-scale dance
models uh use model parallelism so gp3
and these other large models what they
do is that they will simply
shout model weights across different
cores
uh yeah we have a question
oh yeah um i just wanted to know because
i think there was like i know if you're
gonna address later but i think
somewhere in a paper it said that um the
more experts you have the more sample
efficient it gets
and i was just like hoping hoping that
you could give us some intuition about
that because i
don't understand why that would be the
case
so i guess
yeah maybe
yeah so i guess like you know there's
all of this work on larger models are
more sample efficient and larger in the
context of the scaling law works means
like more parameters and more flops as
you increase the number of experts
there's more parameters but not more
flops but the model is still like you
know larger in in like you know a
similar sense so i guess like building
on the intuition that larger models are
more sample efficient in my mind it's
not necessarily that surprising
that
these models with more experts that have
more parameters are more sample
efficient
i guess that's my like kind of high
level uh intuition for it
yeah i would say that's kind of expected
that you know
more experts
leads to better sample efficiency
especially if you look at trending step
right
in our training time
okay cool
so where are we um
yeah so yes so
okay so we look at how model weights are
split over cost for different scenarios
um so data parallelism is the first one
so that's kind of the
the typical setup that deep learning uh
uses
um especially for not so large networks
which don't require another parallelism
and so let me yeah let me explain how
yeah i'll just go to the final
figure and i'll explain how to look at
this figure
okay so we have 16 processors which are
organized in a four by four mesh right
so each dotted line
each four by four dotted line here
represents a different core
and the first row studies how the model
weights are split over course and the
second row
illustrates how data so literally
examples and tokens are split over
course
and yeah and then the final thing to
that's required to understand this
figure is that each
um
yeah each color of the shaded squares
here uh identifies a unique weight
matrix
okay so let's start with data
parallelism
so for data parallelism
uh the same model weights are replicated
across all cores
and the data is simply partitioned of
our cause and so
that's what um this corresponds to
um
you know if you
like using the
the
description of the caption the
explanation of the caption i just gave
so next we have model parallelism
that's kind of just like a theoretical
example because in practice people
always use modal parallelism in
conjunction with data parallelism
but so if you want to do only model
parallelism now you would have a single
model way that is partitioned over all
cores
and your data would just be replicated
over all codes instead
so now we have modeling data parallelism
and that's kind of the typical scenario
for large dense networks
so in that case model weights are
partitioned among a subset of the course
to subset of course that process
different batches of data
and so in that example here we have
you know sort of four uh so the first
sub-square here means that
the model weights are
partitioned across four score four cores
and um
and this is replicated
sort of four times for the data
parallelism dimension
on the data side for model and data
parallelism um
yeah the data here
is replicated across model parallel
cores and partitioned across data
parallel cores
so next we have expert and data
parallelism
so in that scenario that's kind of
similar to data parallelism but now each
core will hold a different model weight
which is illustrated by the different
colors
and for the data side the data is simply
replicated
sorry the layer is partitioned across
all cores
just like in the data parallelism
scenario
and so finally we have uh the rightmost
column which is um
i guess yeah that's the setup used in
the switch transformer paper for the
larger models
and so here for the model
partitioning each expert this partition
across multiple cores so in that example
we have four experts
each partition across four cores
and the data is replicated across
multiple
cores and partitioned across data
parallel cores
so that's a that's a little bit um you
know complex too
to understand already but the sweet
transformer paper has a nice the same
figure with a nice caption to explain it
and yeah maybe we can um
you know about it we can add something
quickly about how this is implemented in
practice
so
there's this paper called mesh
transformer which kind of extends
batch or data parallelism to more
general purpose spmd style programming
and so different labs have different you
know frameworks but this paper kind of
lays the foundation for
um
general spmd distributed computing which
is
required for training large-scale models
and so under the the mesh abstraction
basically we have a mesh of processes
um
which ha and so that mesh has dimensions
name dimensions and these name
dimensions specify how
the tensor dimensions will be
partitioned or replicated across the
mesh dimensions
and so just that simple abstraction um
sort of supports you know data
parallelism also model parallelism and
especially expert parallelism uh at once
and so you know i invite whoever is
interested to to also check that paper
because that's kind of
um
you know that kind of lays the
foundation for understanding these
things
all right barry's want to go cool yeah
so next we're going to kind of talk
about like how we take these parallelism
strategies and like kind of combine them
together to make like a a 1.6 trillion
parameter sparse model
so next slide
so so here so what we ended up doing in
this work was we had we um
trained two different very large sparks
models and we compared them to the
largest t5 model so we can see the t5
xxl which is a dense model and it was
the largest one trained in the p5 paper
and it has around 13 billion parameters
and here we list a lot of the model
dimensions like the model dff which are
just like you know the various sizes and
shapes of the of the tensors and stuff
the number of layers the number of heads
and importantly we also mentioned the
negative log perplexity
um at step 250k and at 500k
and so yeah so we designed two sparse
models to test and i have to test like
how scaling
versus sparsity versus scaling versus
sparsity and flops work
so first let me talk about switch xl so
that has the same amount of flops per
token as t5x xl but has 64 experts and
this leads it to have around 400 billion
parameters
and we can see that on a step basis it
actually performs quite well and
outperforms the t5 xxl by like quite a
good margin
interestingly though our the third model
we designed switch c which has 1.6
trillion parameters but has
significantly fewer flops almost 10 less
flops per token than either of the above
two models so it's really trading by
reducing flops that have way more sparse
parameters
and we can see on a step basis
the the switch c model uh works well but
not not as well as actually the higher
flop model
but on uh like a kind of a pareto axis
where we're looking at tpu hours on the
x-axis and not step the switch c model
actually outperforms them both by like a
pretty large margin so for pre-training
performance we're seeing that actually
just like having a lot of sparsity and
less flops is actually um can be quite
good
next slide
yeah and so yeah this so again those two
sparse models are kind of really trying
to get at this hypothesis that actually
gnome shazier had which is you know
that you know parameters are good for
more knowledge
reasoning and compute aka flops is good
for intelligence
and so we're going to kind of try to get
at that by taking these different sparse
models and then fine-tuning them on uh
different tasks some of which require
more like knowledge and then others
which require more of like reasoning
for whatever like handwave definition we
want to give that
so yeah so for a fixed oh go back so
yeah so for a fix
oh can you go back to the previous slide
oh yes sorry okay so for a fixed quality
on an upstream pre-training task
um yeah do parameters independently
matter
so we're going to look at two tasks here
one of which is super glue which is kind
of our like reasoning task and then
another is like trivia qa which is like
some knowledge task where it's like you
just give it a question you have it
output an answer
okay
and so here we're going to take a look
at super group quality so we can see on
the x-axis is the pre-training
performance and the y-axis is the super
glue score after fine-tuning
and interestingly we can see definitely
that the sparse models definitely are
for a fixed
pre-training perplexity do worse on
fine-tuning this can be especially
noticed at like the upper right portion
of the plot where the dense models are
definitely fine-tuning better than the
their sparse counterpart
next slide
interestingly when we study it on the
more knowledge-heavy tasks the sparse
model for a fixed uh pre-training
perplexity does disproportionately well
so you know for a model that roughly has
the same perplexity we're getting like
really large boosts for these
knowledge-heavy tasks so this is pretty
interesting and it also really
you know shows some of the dangers of
comparing only on your pre-training
metrics so these models you know can
have the same exact preaching metric but
very different um
you know properties when fine-tuning
them on different tasks
next slide
and interestingly so yeah all of the
switch models here are the um are just
like you know various models
that have still a good amount of flops
but the red model is actually the 1.6
trillion parameter
sparse model that has you know very few
flops
but a lot a lot of parameters and we can
see that as the red dot here and it does
actually disproportionately bad compared
to other sparse models that also have
pretty good perplexities and so yeah
it's uh it's definitely very interesting
and it shows that you know for models
during pre-training that have a lot of
sparsity they definitely suffer on some
of these more reasoning heavy metrics
but do disproportionately well for more
of these knowledge-heavy tasks
uh next slide
yeah and so here we can see it as just
like a huge outlier
for a pre-trained perplexity doing like
just
incredibly well on this uh downstream
question answering task
next slide
yeah okay so also you know one thing
that we were gonna do is just look at
the fine-tuning properties of sparse
models across like a few scales and just
see how they perform
next slide
yeah and so here we try two different
models one is um
t5 bass and then we make a flop match
sparse counterpoint and when they say
flat matched it's like you know each
token will have the same amount of flops
but now we just have experts so we do
this for both base and large and we see
that actually across almost all tasks
besides two arc tasks the sparse models
perform quite well which is which is
definitely promising so we are seeing
that these models are pretty robust they
pre-train well and then they also
fine-tune well when scaled appropriately
by scaling up both the flops and
sparsity
whereas you know the negative results
we've really seen are like yeah when you
just have a huge amount of sparsity and
not too many flops
next slide
yeah and one also thing we wanted to
look at was uh the multilingual training
so we were previously studying all of
this on like english only and we also
wanted to see how sparsity helps in the
multilingual setting because you know we
also felt like this would be a very
natural place for sparse city to work
well where potentially experts could
specialize across languages
and we do see strong results so on 91 of
the languages
i think of like around 100 languages we
see over like at least the forex speed
up
over the mt5
dense model
next
slide
you want to go ahead
uh no go go ahead okay yeah so
another thing we wanted to talk about
was
distillation so one downside of these
sparse models is that they'll have a lot
more parameters which means that you
know if you're serving these things or
something you either need like high
throughput use cases
or you need to maybe distill it back
down into like a smaller dense model
so here what we do is we look at like
the t5 base and switchbase and we look
at its pre-training performance and then
we go through some ablations of
different distillation techniques and
find that like with the best techniques
we can keep around 30 of the quality
improvements of sparsity while
distilling it back down into its dense
counterpart so next slide
yeah and then we kind of study this
across multiple scales and again we see
like around like 30 to 40 percent of the
gains can be um
like you know kept when going from a
dense mod when going from you know a
sparse model distilling it back down
into like its flop match dense model so
you can get you know
get rid of up to 99 of the parameters
and still keep like around 30 of the
improvements which is very promising
next slide wait i'm sorry yeah
all right sorry about that can you say
that last sentence again you said that
you can keep the benefit 30 of the
teachers benefit
yeah basically so yeah you you yeah
exactly
yeah
yeah so we're looking at like yeah you
train a sparse model and then you
distill it back onto a dense model
and you're versus training a dense model
from scratch and like you look at the
gap between the sparse and dense model
from scratch versus the the the gap
between the dance and the distilled
dance model
what do you mean
you go forward
oh yes yeah
oh yeah maybe let me just do like a
quick high level summary again so yeah
what we'll do is for our comparisons is
we'll train a dense model from scratch
we'll train a sparse model from scratch
and then we'll also run a third
experiment where we distill that sparse
model down into a dense model
what does distilling mean
like we're basically trying to match the
uh like the teacher's logits
like the kind of standard thing of like
you know like matching the like either
the logits or like the soft
probabilities for each token or
something like that
okay if i can jump in with my question
so what i'm struggling with is how do i
interpret the line that says percent of
teacher and performance
yeah okay so it's basically looking at
the like the gap between the dense and
sparse model
so we'll have the dense model get some
performance we'll have the sparse model
get some performance and then the um the
dense model is still from the sparse
model be somewhere in between that that
range and we're basically saying it's 30
through that range so it's like in like
a zero one interval it's like point
three of the way from the dense to the
sparse model i see so this is not saying
that the percent of teacher performance
does not mean that if the teachers say
it's if we use the teacher's uh uh
guesses or predictions as the ground
truth this is not saying that the
distilled model gets matches with the
the teacher 33 of the time
no no exactly it's basically saying you
get like 30 of the the quality
improvements yeah exactly okay cool um
and then if we can back up the slide i
had a different question but i didn't
want to interrupt um
when we were talking about all of these
different t5 bases and then also on this
a few slides before this
i don't know that much about t5 i'm
curious to know when t5 is trained is
there a weight penalty in the lost
function
is there a weight decay turn
no there's no weight decay trained with
any of those sparse or dense models i
see so out of curiosity then how do
dense models perform compared to the
switch model if you add some sort of
weight regularization that incentivizes
getting rid of useless weights
oh so some kind of like maybe like l1
term or something like that yeah so i'm
just wondering like how much of because
here we're talking about the benefits of
sparsity and i'm wondering how much of
this benefit from sparsity is due to the
fact that just some of this i mean
effectively what the switch model is
doing if i understand correctly maybe i
don't what i understand is that the
switch model the feed forward layer it's
just like you you fixing the weight to
be zero that's what it means to be smart
well actually we're kind of really
trying to like inject more weights so
we're actually kind of trying to do it's
a little bit maybe like paradoxical
because we're saying switch transformer
but our idea is to be like hey we
actually want to just have significantly
more weights
not less it's kind of like you you would
zero out weights but within a
much larger weight matrix if that makes
sense i see yes and so to me it seems
like a relevant bass line to just ask
what happens if i have the dense matrix
but i incentivize it would say an l1 or
l2 penalty on the weights and i would be
curious to know how that compares
yeah we didn't run this but also that
kind of gets rid of weights for the
dense model so if anything
so yeah
yeah and the last point is like if you
just add like an l1 penalty loss um
you're not gonna have structured
sparsity
whereas like here we
you know
it's not random weights in your giant
weight matrix there are zero that right
it's like really like blocks depending
uh like blocks corresponding to each
expo
right so that that structure allows the
the whole like communication stuff and
and that that's
yes what leverage is the fact that you
have multiple calls and so on right so i
i totally agree with that block
structure and and that's what i'm trying
to say is that the switch has this very
rich it's it's not just sparse it also
has this rich structure and what i'm
trying to do in my mind is disentangle
is the sparsity what's offering an
advantage or is this additional
structure that you built in is that what
is the performance
so that's why i'm asking
so so the the
the block structure is what
enables to leverage the fact that you
have multiple calls like if you if you
didn't have that block structure you'd
still have to route to everything
and so you have more communication costs
and so on so um and then your first
question was what sorry
i'm not actually sure if there was a
question i guess what i'm trying to say
is i'm trying to disambiguate yeah
anyways
but i agree it's a little bit weird
because sparsity kind of
there's like a spectrum of meaning for
sparsity right was like for example
compression and
like model pruning is a form of sparsity
but also
uh sweet transformer and emily also
referred to as sparsity and
that kind of related but definitely
they're aiming at different things so
this is a really interesting idea of
it's sparse but you have more parameters
i'll have to think about it more thank
you
yeah yeah like it's kind of like spots
within this like giant weight matrix
which is
yeah
yeah yeah i hadn't appreciated that so i
appreciate you you pointing that out
thank you
i have a follow-up question distillation
part
yeah of course okay so if you distill it
back down now you have like one
technically you're back to the dense
layer architecture right
um
so now the entire like the entire idea
of expert is that certain tokens would
be sent to different experts because
they just like i don't know are more
specialized in figuring something out
about this token
um so now if you go back to this like
dense layer
like aren't you like basically only
serving whatever
like um whichever expert you base the
stance later on like these tokens will
probably perform well and all the other
tokens are kind of like left behind
right
i'm actually sorry i don't think i'm
fully understanding your question so
that so are you kind of getting at like
we're displaying this on a specific data
set
so
that i'm thinking about how to use that
like why
yeah
yeah yeah so maybe concretely like let's
so like for super glue right let's say
you want to serve a model that does
super glue well i think the idea is that
like you distill the sparse model into a
dense model on super glue so then you
kind of get this compressed dense model
that now performs better than if you
were to just you know train it from
scratch or train it from like a
pre-trained dense model so then it's
like did you use them
say that again
you you have to pick one expert right no
no you can just distill all of the cause
you're just matching the the model
outputs so you can just treat the sparse
model as kind of like a black box thing
all we're doing is just trying to have
the dense model match the actual like
final like you know token predictions oh
god okay you got it okay sorry i was not
i was not familiar with the idea of the
distillation so i think that was like my
entire confusion okay thanks yeah of
course yeah um
because i i guess
one motivation here is that
um having experts can make serving a
little bit more difficult because
um it requires bigger topologies let's
say you have eight experts
um
you need like
well i guess you can have multiple
experts on on fewer calls but
um
you know legislated a little bit harder
to solve and so if we can you know get
the benefits
from sparsi at pre-training
then use distillation
to a dense model for serving uh that can
be that can be beneficial so i think
that was sort of the motivation for that
experiment right
yeah exactly
uh okay where were we yeah
yes i kind of just wrapping okay go
ahead
no go ahead ben i just said i think uh
one more string kind of question so yeah
so yeah go ahead i feel here to ask
enough oh yeah yeah sounds good um yeah
thank you guys for the talk so far uh
just a quick question was wondering if
you think there are any interesting
directions around uh building models
that are like explicitly optimized for
for parallel training um i guess like
the the moe model seems like you know it
does a really good job here and also
like at inference time it's you know
very useful to like you know have fewer
uh flops per per computation um
but for forward pass but um i i guess do
you think there are any interesting
directions around distributed training
where you might have like models that
are explicitly
are architected to
have a lot of uh
parallel heads or or other like
features that are you know kind of
embarrassingly parallelizable or does
just using like standard you know
scale up the models by adding more
layers
and then just you know get away with
using model and data parallelism work
well enough
yeah so i think so yeah so let me just
make sure i'm fully understanding so
yeah i think also like you know right
now like even our models are definitely
very co-designed with the hardware and
like the shapes and things you know um
so yeah i i think at a high level like
yes i think there's a ton of interesting
research on like co-designing the
hardware the partitioning algorithms and
the models
i think given you know that we have this
kind of like spmd mesh style
partitioning we are already kind of
designing our models in ways that fit it
really well so for example when we want
to scale up our model one of the first
dimensions we go to scale up is the
internal hidden dimension because
there's some really nice properties of
scaling up this dimension it basically
becomes like kind of you know
independent to some of the communication
costs it's really good when looking at
the compute to memory operations on
these you know like uh compute devices
and stuff
yeah exactly like i think when we're
even designing these models we're like
really setting dimensions such that it
maps well onto hardware
um so it's almost like you know given
that we have this model data parallelism
we're like actually
designing models more for it but i also
think that there's a ton of new
interesting distributed algorithms and
stuff like that which makes designing
models very interesting like i think one
thing that i think is really cool is
like the microsoft zero partitioning too
which also like adds some really new
like nice implications for like how to
design and scale models and stuff so
yeah i think there's like this is a very
fruitful research direction
um if that kind of answered your
question
yeah no that was super helpful and
interesting thanks yeah
yeah definitely like i'm very optimistic
on the future of us like designing the
hardware the model the partitioning
strategies all together because really
to get it to work well you kind of have
to know about all three and like kind of
you know intertwine the development of
them yeah yeah that sounds awesome
yeah so just to summarize it's like yeah
so switch transformer is like a nice
simplification over a mixture of experts
and we're seeing that we get really
strong speed up improvements on
pre-training over like a lot of the t5
models which are very strong baselines
we're seeing that we can you know
efficiently distill the sparse models
back to dense ones
and you know get improved both
pre-training and fine-tuning through
some of these newer techniques we talked
about
and we're also seeing that the models
are working on multilingual data and
that we can you know now easily
successfully train up to you know 1.6
trillion parameter models which is
pretty promising
and um next slide and so we also wanted
to go into two slides about some like
newer work about actually using these
kind of models for computer vision and
actually also a little bit of how they
can be used to actually do some level of
like adaptive computation where not only
now each input gets different weights
but also sometimes different inputs will
have different amounts of compute
applied to it
and yeah so there's some really great
work of doing this out of the the google
zurich team and yeah they're just doing
it for image classification and you know
they're basically seeing a lot of the
similar types of scaling properties
where you know scaling up the number of
experts and using sparsity allows them
to get good um performances on image
classification
um next slide
and interestingly one of the things they
do is like as we talk about the capacity
factor so we were talking about values
of like 1 1.25 2.0 which means like at a
value of 2.0 there's buffer for you know
two tokens per expert but they actually
study it going less than one so that
means that like at 0.5 that means
there's only like room for half the
number of tokens
and the nice part is is that they did
this for image classification and also
in images there's just a lot of
redundancy
and they notice that you can actually
get really good performance by only
allowing like you know up to one tenth
of the the parts of the image to be
processed by a sparse layer so yeah we
think this is like a really nice
direction too in terms of combining
sparsity along with like adaptive
computation
and yeah and uh yeah thanks so much for
having us
that's that's the talk
so thank you
uh barrett and
um
sorry are you fun for coming here
uh so you know
uh so i will just like ask a bunch of
questions and then we can have like uh
after the class uh
open question panel for the students
uh so one thing is like have you tried
using like like more like linear
attention mechanisms like reformers and
like other stuff uh to like scale the
computation
um um
i personally have maybe
i haven't personally done this
yes so
oh you know i guess we can maybe comment
on how um
you know the attention
the cost coming from the attention maps
isn't
the dominant costs in
in this large transformers
um so you know the motivation for using
linear attention um like performers is
that
it reduces uh the quadratic cost of
attention that's right um
but
so far i mean at least you know in like
sort of typical nlp setups like super
glue c4 and so on
as you scale the models most of the
memory
comes from the the model weights as
opposed to attention to the attention
maps
that's also because you know using very
long
context or sequence length
doesn't prove that fruitful and so
you know just uh you know working with
the vanilla self-attention mechanism is
uh is a very strong baseline already
got it okay
um so another question is like uh do you
think this uh like mechanism is even
more scalable like can you go on and
build like 10 trillion parameter models
stuff like that like what do you think
yeah definitely i think yeah totally i
think honestly the one of the biggest
constraints is that like you know and
this isn't even necessarily constrained
it's just like you have to fit the
parameter somewhere and there's just
limited storage on devices but if you
get enough devices such that you know
yeah you can just partition the weights
it's like yeah i don't see anything
stopping it
got it so what do you think personally
is your like uh
like the thing like with the direction
like uh like scaling of transformers
will go into like uh will be more like
works that are trying to just like use
transformer like mechanisms like
minister of experts or do you think
there's like you're going to be other
things that the community needs
yeah i mean i definitely think mixture
of experts should find its way or at
least you know sparse players like
switch transformers
will definitely i think find their way
into like the future of large models i
think they really confer a lot of
benefits
and they're also very good in like high
throughput applications so i think the
one thing like so the one downside is on
sparsity is like if you look at the
performance per model weight they're
going to always be worse than bounce
models so it's like if you really are
constrained on like i want to design the
best model i can to fit on as small of a
device as i can then they're probably
not going to be the best solution
because the sparse weights just aren't
as good as just the dense weight that's
being used for everything
so i think it really depends on the
application but i'm very optimistic for
when we're training these models during
pre-training with lots of data
parallelism and then we're serving them
and like medium to higher throughput
examples i feel like they could actually
just be a pretty big win
so that that's kind of my thoughts on on
how i think sparsity will be used in
terms of other things yeah i think i
don't know there's a ton of exciting
research you know from everything from
yeah like a lot of the linear attention
stuff adaptive computation new
pre-training objectives you know yeah
it's hard to know what the future will
look like but uh yeah a lot of exciting
things to look forward to
it sounds good okay uh so we can now
have like a round of student questions
so we'll just stop the recording